ap
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci
si leur mari
et
[Musique]
ici charles tac bois qui vous parle
depuis l'appartement d'adriano tivio dit
ni dans le drame bouleverse depuis huit
jours toute l'italie qui exactement une
semaine que les brigades jaunes ont
enlevé micha le nounours du célèbre
milliardaire romain pour la première
fois aujourd'hui ils acceptent de parler
à la télévision le temps que je me rende
jusqu'à lui je vous propose de suivre un
bref résumé des principaux évènements
mardi rome effaré après en se réveillant
que les brigades jaunes ont encore
frappé
elles vont enlever micha le petit
nounours du célèbre homme d'affaires
italien adriano thé glee juli ni
mercredi les brigades jaune selon leur
habitude font parvenir cette photo à la
presse preuve qu'elles sont bien en
possession de micha et qu'il est encore
vivant une rançon de 20 milliards de
lires est réclamée contre l'avis de
misha la police demande à la famille de
ne pas céder jeudi
les brigades jeunes répliquent en
faisant parvenir par la poste au
domicile du milliardaire une oreille de
misha menaçant de les couper l'autre
s'il n'accepte pas de payer aussitôt
l'industriel romain fait savoir malgré
la police qu'il est prêt à payer
ils demandent où il doit déposer les 20
milliards de lires
et depuis plus rien pas de réponse
le silence le silence horrible de la
tente
mais elle avait donné que j'étais 3
suite à là depuis forcément j'ai
toujours emmener avec moi partout j'ai
ramené toujours l'art à la schola
l'universitaire a le bureau si ou quand
je les vois ministre ministre et les
femmes aussi
ce coût aux atouts est aussi papa pape
piquet avait dit le pape
l'arménie je comprends bien mich a été
pour vous donner des plus jamais annoncé
le nom des loups c'était mon mari
pourquoi il avait acheté au style et les
puits de pétrole et six au texas et
quand je t'ai l'élite wyatt de comment
il s'appelle christophe si le grec l'a
alors toujours j'aurais amené avec moi
comme les prix du transit au texas
je n'en menais toujours toujours texte
si vous n'avez pas dormi depuis le jour
de l'enlèvement
est ce exact mais c'est vrai pic et pic
et il n'était pas de mise en bourse
madail acquis qui peut dormir ça
s'annonce qui vous pouvez vous pouvez
dormir ça rend trousses
alors si elle trouve quoi cet hommage
pourtant vous avez reçu des témoignages
d'amitié du monde entier soit un par
jour trent ainsi guardi alors merci tout
à la gentry très gentille merci merci
beaucoup mais ce n'est pas méchant
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
michaud si si si marcello si mama
j'attendais tommy les foi qui était
petit et sami ne doivent pas téléphoner
toutes les 10 minutes en ce moment mal
non si c'est cette force et sans fil
je n'ai pas patiné pour l'instant
combien de kidnapper mon petit frère si
le dénivelé vous faire un appel au
ravisseur aussi dans la caméra s'il vous
plaît dans le souci de la qualité
surtout suite ou ne lui fait pas de mal
puisqu'elle est très fragile et zut ou
alors ne ne se coupe pas comme ça ou
comme ça là pascal aulas le mécanisme
est petit à l'intérieur sous bloc là et
elle a une balle blue du tout me le
rende et je vous donnerai tout
mon docteur non pas le docteur mon usine
mon château ma femme a sitôt et non ici
tous mes rendez moi mon ours bruns des
mois micha niche je pense à toi moi
j'aimais d'oubli par mois je vous en
prie monsieur tu as il doit se reposer
je vous en prie vous devez comprendre
fifa 12
[Musique]
c'est sur l'image bouleversante
l'un des hommes les plus puissants
d'italie que l'on tente vainement de
faire dormir sans son nounours que je
vous rend l'antenne
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur c'est le ministère des
gens nous procédons actuellement au
recensement des cons j'aimerais savoir
ce qui vous concerne vous êtes cons
j'aimerais mieux pas parler de ça au
téléphone on va écouter ça fait rien je
repasserai enfin comme ça d'accord enfin
monsieur merci
[Musique]
c
gt gt sable
[Musique]
en classe
m
et
[Musique]
aïe aïe
non
[Musique]
ça fait mal et
ces trois là
[Musique]
je suis
derrière
[Musique]
charest
cet homme vous le connaissez bien c'est
le facteur c'est votre ami
chaque jour il vous apporte des
nouvelles d'une personne chère d'un
parent éloigné ou de l'être aimé
bonjour madame j'ai un petit paquet pour
vous aujourd'hui
merci monsieur rien madame monsieur ou
madame cet homme vous relie au monde
mais aujourd'hui le laisser-aller et la
négligence de certains d'entre nous
rendre sa tâche chaque jour plus
difficile
[Musique]
or madame et salage et aux rousses et
pas ici c'est au 44 ah oui pardon
excusez moi
au revoir madame
[Musique]
il ne peut plus travailler comme avant
son bon métier perd en qualité en
précision et en harmonie de plus la joie
du labeur celle employée des postes
risque de s'étioler
madame du bout sans abri j'ai un
recommandé pour vous y entrez pourtant
consciencieux le facteur continue à
exercer sa profession de son mieux pour
que vos missives arrive toujours à
l'heure et à bon port signez là s'il
vous plaît
madame cela doit cesser
nous devons tous faire un effort pour
faciliter le travail du facteur et lui
redonner sa joie de vivre
pensez à nous écrivait proprement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'entomologiste louis xi coup ci vient
de rester immergés trois jours et trois
nuits dans les marais de camargue il
nous déclare seuls les moustiques mal
rasé pique les autres mordent istanbul
employés des postes à istanbul monsieur
jean-pierre km 24 ans a réussi à briser
en deux 63 briques en moins de 30
minutes à la seule force de ses mains à
notre connaissance c'est la première
fois qu'un tueur que s'appelle
jean-pierre le célèbre historien
françois francine nous déclare si newton
avait épousé denis papin nous aurions
connu la pomme vapeur bien avant 1880
marseille après avoir découvert le
remède contre le rhume des foins le
silicate de permanganate le vilebrequin
à air chaud les lys à double révolution
le grand savant français achille
parterre découvre en ouvrant le placard
de sa chambre qu'il est cocu moscou nos
conversations se sont déroulées sur un
pied d'égalité totale a déclaré le
ministre des affaires étrangères de
verrès monsieur gromyko à l'issue de son
entretien avec son homologue polonais
monsieur petit mytho
[Musique]
et
dites moi monsieur ouvre à vous avez
sorti la lettre 745 bx e32 du classement
14 noms alors faites-le évita incroyable
ça ça c'est pas moi
dites-moi ouvrard qui s'occupe de la
cantine ici c'est vous c'est moi c'est
moi le chef
alors qu'est ce que c'est que ça où voir
la prochaine fois que je retrouve une
banane qui a cette odeur sentais bien et
qui a des petits trous comme ça porto
des petits trous et un gros trou la
prochaine fois je ne vous dirais que
deux mots vie nous ouvre à vous appeler
ça de la mise en page vous et bon mois
par mois moi j'appelle ça la cochonnerie
alors vous allez me recommencer ça
immédiatement ouvrard le patron envoie
pour vous dire d'être un peu plus
souriant avec chacun de nous vous
comprendrez ce que ça veut dire ouvra
alors souriant sous riant souriant sous
nos outils
dites moi on verra c'est bien vous qui
vous êtes servis de la colle en dernier
fonctionne maintenant alors détaché
plein trip le crétin alors cette lettre
ouvrage
[Musique]
mais la gare
bon week-end à tous mes enfants vont
bien
lundi beaucoup de travail
ce passage là bas ça fait vraiment du
bien
[Musique]
j'ai testé pour vous la belle soeur
tendre et où piqué 15 avenue bosquet
votre cours et franchement je ne le
regrette pas franchement parce que j'ai
testé pour vous le proverbe qui volent à
9 vole un boeuf
je regarderai pas j'ai testé pour vous
la nouvelle sesay de cabriolets de
litres elle est un peu survireuse
surtout dans les virages mais
confortable jadis tout part à vau par
part à vos parents vos autres os la sk
espagnol apparat correspondant à sa part
à la posta est à bono face à bobigny
c'est bien pourtant la veille au soir
elle était partie du premier couple à
rien alors je dis à jeanine et ça c'est
la tête de d je vais voir tenez vous
bien
c'était pas la tête de telco c'était la
durite
ça commence à aller mieux la bière va
continuer encore un peu donc je veux
jamais dû dit tiens toi bien c'est pas
la tête de delcourt c'est la durite et
jeanine me faire barça ça m'étonne pas à
chaque fois c'est le même truc on croit
que c'est la tête de la corée puis
finalement c'est la durite aurait ça
soulage bien essayé de bouger doucement
aux têtes ne sentais rien aucune douleur
non parfait passez-vous le sinus en
expirant doucement
nous fait mal oui ça me lance encore un
peu bougez pas on va arranger ça donc
j'aurai par la durite hélas jeanine me
fais un bas nylon le gigot il va plutôt
être trop cuit s'il est nouveau ça fait
plus mal du tout parfait on veut vous
rhabiller se terminer oh merci docteur
soudoie combien celle sang-froid docteur
dessin grêle nous venons d'assister à
votre consultation
je crois que vous êtes un des tout
premiers médecins à pratiquer l'accueil
aux thérapies c'est exact la culotte et
rapide est une technique très nouvelle
qui n'est pas encore très répandu je
pense que nous sommes à peu près
douzaine de kilos thérapeute soit paris
et un en quoi consiste exactement là le
kilo thérapie la kg thérapie et est un
traitement tout nouveau pour guérir les
céphalées ce qu'on appelle couramment
les migraines
qu'elles soient d'origine ophtalmique et
bateaux billiers informel botulique mais
alors ces méthodes curatives peut
s'appliquer à tous les patients atteints
de céphalées non non nous n'appliquons
pas tous les patients
ah bon mais alors comment que l'essai
voulait les patients que vous pouvez
soigner grâce à la queue leu thérapie en
général ils viennent nous trouver en
disant qu aux âmes en cuma tu étais
malade a bien bien je voudrais docteur
vous poser juste une dernière question
je vous ne vous sentez pas bien et sous
des moines nous avons des journées
épuisantes
oui je peux faire quelque chose pour
vous c'est pas trop vous demander si ce
n'est pas de refus
merci beaucoup
oui je sais il était une fois une
princesse non n'arrive pas plutôt une
recette de cuisine sur une recette de
cuisine les contes de fées ça ne me
réussit pas ça empire plutôt oui
bon alors là que pour bien réussir votre
cas et au raisin de préférence il vaut
mieux avoir un faitout en cuivre et 1 kg
de muscat ah oui ça soulage bien aimé
une caille bien fraîche ça fait du bien
bien fraîche lacaille aulas que c'est
bon et alors le mieux c'est de l'art
déco et vous la mettez dans le faitout
on the do et dans lequel vous avez fait
fondre 200 g de beurre aussi miraculeux
bien frais aussi comme la caille le
beurre au
[Musique]